as the East braces for a major winter
storm frigid cold already created a
frozen spectacle in Maine
a giant disc of ice in a river near
Portland is drawing international
attention now it was first spotted
Monday morning David Berg know is there
along the river in Westbrook Maine where
the ice disc has formed David good
morning to you and what's the name of
that River Gail it's the Presumpscot
River good morning to you on a 10-degree
date look this is the story of how what
went around came around you know kids
love frozen the musical this is frozen
the mystery we got a drone with us get a
good look as this Randy punches it up
looking at it you might understand why
some think it's the far side of the Moon
others joked that hey it came from
aliens well the cold hard truth this
morning is this did not come from outer
space
if symmetry in nature is what you're
looking for welcome to Westbrook Maine
last word is now famous for this
spinning ice disc which is great how did
the ice get made
it is a whopping 300 feet wide the
frozen disc had been spinning on the
Presumpscot River for the last 72 hours
but it stopped yesterday that didn't
stop the people who wanted to see it
though I was just speaking to my sister
in England I said we've made national
news and she said no you have made
national you've made international you
were just on the BBC rare natural
phenomenon taking shape in the US state
of Maine is mesmerizing people around
the world what is going on here it's
Maine the air is cold you get ice Eric
Fischer is the chief meteorologist at
our CBS station WBZ in Boston he says
the rotation of the ice can be driven by
the current of the river but also by the
temperature changes in the water
underneath the ice eric says that
creates a vortex that causes it to spin
there sure in this case X is almost like
a grinding wheel where the ice hits the
coast and it starts to shave off and it
creates this perfect pizza shape of the
ice discs they're floating in the water
they're fairly rare we may hear about
these once or twice a winter Steven Daly
specializes in river ice hydraulics for
the Army Corps of Engineers he says
while ice discs are not unheard of
the ones he's seen are much smaller
ranging from 30 to only 50 feet they had
the perfect combination of air
temperature ice production and flow
conditions for this to form and it may
not happen again for a number of years
so about 18 hours ago it stopped
spinning and what happened is you can
see the ice disc the the bottom corner
of it has sort of attached to the side
right so the ice is formed and now it's
it's stuck if you will but that hasn't
stopped people from coming to see it I
mean this is like the main tourist
attraction in town right now and you
know it's 2019 so of course the ice disc
has to have its own Twitter account I
just checked the most recent tweet was
anyone have an ice pick I think I have a
few frosted flakes stuck in my teeth
we got a good one David you look happy
to be there but tell us the truth you'd
prefer to be in Puerto Rico like you
were last year yeah remember this is a
Louie look this is a Louisiana boy who
had never been to Maine I was so excited
to come but when they said ten degrees I
said okay y'all this is real